and now for the first time in color the
38
one of the highlights of Academy Award
night is the arrival of glittering
celebrities such stars as Jason Robards
in Joanne Woodward Dorothy Malone P
Marvin mr. Gregory Peck
Kim Novak
Shelly Withers
firmly she and Peter Ustinov Shirley
MacLaine and Warren Beatty
Julie Andrews
Natalie would
Julie Christie
mr. Jack Lemmon
Lynda Bird Johnson and escort George
Hamilton
Makana Spain looks like a Lloyd Bridges
rumpus room
all right rain jet all right
how do you do ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the agony and the ecstasy
Santa Monica version now this is the
38th annual edition of roar the
greasepaint smell of the crowd this is a
great night for the Hollywood stars
tonight we clean slate set aside our
petty differences forget old feuds and
start new ones now I'm sure we're going
to have a great show this evening before
we went on the air Rex Harrison put on
his robes and bless the stage we have a
very distinguished audience here tonight
as befits this great occasion sitting
out there the stars of today and the
Senators of tomorrow
but I'm delighted to be back here again
for my 12th year of penance for the next
two hours you'll see me helping to hand
out the Oscars and smiling I've been
preparing for it all week sleeping on a
bed of nails now I never had a chance
this year I can't drink like Lee Marvin
I can't grunt like Rod Steiger
I can't enunciate like Olivier and when
it comes to Burton I'm really in trouble
tonight are some of the greatest
performers in the world the greatest
producer is the greatest director of the
greatest writers and you're going to see
some of the greatest acting when they
congratulate each other but isn't it
exciting
all over America people are saying to
each other I wonder who will win and all
over Beverly Hills psychiatrists and
dusting off their couches are saying I
wonder who losers this is a tense moment
for the nominees st. Christopher medals
and mezuzahs are at a premium aspire
scores once said there are no atheists
on Academy Award night
now the tension in this room is
tremendous the strain is so great Ronald
Regan coughed and Governor Brown said
bless you and I know that George
Hamilton is here with a beautifully
feathered friend
then the Bird Johnson
and if he plays his cards right he may
be the second Hamilton on the White
House
that is if he swears allegiance to Texas
the cameras will be picking up the
contestants in our audience from time to
time so I'd like to caution our
glamorous stars if you've got an itch
forget it